distinguished Mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen
first of all I should just like to
greet our
invitee the president of Algeria Mr
taboon and for thank him for finding
time to visit our
Forum here in Saint Petersburg thank you
very much
uh
Mr chairman and I should like to address
my words also to the other
foreign guests here
first of all of course our forum is
dedicated to the development of Russia
across the board all spheres concerned
and I would say that this really is very
important event for us
inasmuch as
we have much to do and we have to decide
exactly what we are going to do in the
very near future and who we will work
with
and I think that the chairman will also
be very interested in that
in as much as
his particular public will be concerned
and
I think that certainly our kind of
economic model could be uh acceptable to
other countries and uh with these
countries will be able to
activate their uh cooperation with us
so I greet you to the
26 International Saint Petersburg
economic forum
well last year when I spoke from this
Tribune
I talked about the difficulties which uh
Russia was coming up against
uh
because of the world situation but I
also said that we believe in The
Sovereign independent approach to
economics and I'd just like to say that
that year was really the most difficult
uh in terms of economic history
and that affected Logistics as much as
anything else and affected every single
aspect of economic life whereas today
ladies and gentlemen I think that we can
say with confidence that the
Road forward which we adopted then by
Russia works
the macroeconomic uh Way Forward which
we outlined then is growing is thriving
and
with regard to the results of the end of
this of the year
the international monetary fund said the
growth is 0.73 but I think that in fact
it will be greater and I think it might
even approach two percent
this will allow our country to maintain
its place
amongst the leading economies of the
world
that can be seen in industry and the
retail trade particularly
and 2.9 percent growth we note with
relate with
um
in relation to last year
which has allowed us to provide for
economic activity on a wide scale
and
the situation as I said last year was
very very cautious amongst the business
community
but it was therefore
absolutely essential to give a very
strong support to business which we did
we supported the
soundest economic institutes in the
country so as I said last year when I
spoke here
I outlined the
overall holistic approach of our
to the Russian economy and I think that
what I said
as a result of a collective work and
reform we've done in the administrative
sphere
we really prepared for these kind of
difficult times and it worked it worked
so what are we talking about we
maintained a responsible balanced uh
um lending policy
we note also a minimal increase in
unemployment and in inflation as World
which is much better than many other
Western countries
and it's uh near to a historic minimum
2.2 percent
such a low rate has absolutely never
been witnessed in our history
so that's very important as far as
macroeconomic
stable macro economics is a real
advantage and it is a real trigger to
development and I think that
in terms of
internal political discussions
we had a lot of discussions in terms of
about in terms of what we lacked
macroeconomics there but I think that
practice has shown that we should not
have been defeatist
using the uh
using the budgetary mechanisms which we
uh introduced
we have not allowed uh prices to flare
and our approach was based on a real
istic estimation of what was going on on
the ground
and we did a lot to support the budget
in terms and that can be seen in the
growing GDP
we have a small deficit but it is small
so State finances are on the whole
balanced
the
slate
deficit has been really due to the fact
that we had to move some of the
deadlines and try and finish things
before time
we have made a lot of progress in terms
of state and Regional programs as well
and we have intensified activity in the
arms and Military sphere and I have to
say that on the whole this justifies
that our approach from an economic point
of view
over
January and February we noted a 9.1
increase in productivity and a similar
kind of figure in the uh months
immediately following that
the export of uh gas and oil
has actually increased and that is very
important because
the success in oil processing and gas
processing has a very immediate knock-on
effect on all the other uh areas of
economic of the economy
in fact there was a lot of speculation
in the west that this would be our
downfall but on the contrary this has
worked very well for us
which has allowed the state
to
maintain the welfare payments
to avoid poverty
and the results are much better than
last year
if you look at that particular category
of our population the lowest income
there has been an increase of something
like 30 percent
and that has affected 1.7 million people
those who are on lowest incomes
no
here absolutely every percent
has a has a meaning is significant
maybe it's not no not so significant in
World terms but I think it is still very
significant the main trend
is that we have been able to support all
this
we have also put up the minimum wage
so in comparison with
the real income
of everyone has actually increased in
the last quarter
and obviously these Tendencies have to
be intensified and strengthened
as far as demand is concerned uh
internal demands we are seeing very
positive uh indications there and that
is obviously having a positive impact on
Regional economics
private initiatives here have been very
important
under the pressure of uh
under the pressure of sanctions people
are saying that Russia has going to have
or gone back rather to a kind of command
economy of the past uh this is uh
absolutely wrong private Enterprise has
forged ahead
and we have replaced the effect of the
uh migration
of international corporations
they couldn't withstand our policies
we
did not Chase anybody out on the
contrary we proposed that they should
think once again about their Russian
partners
but each of our partners had the right
to decide what they wanted to do
but the productivity in question has
actually been compensated for by our
domestic productivity
yourself
so in fact many of these businesses have
become Russian businesses even though
they have Western logos
we have done a lot also to support the
wages of workers
in the business sphere
last year of course our businessmen were
very worried about the
exit of the Hemorrhage of Western firms
but
this has been compensated for
particularly in terms of the clothes
industry issues and so on that now
Russian interpret no Russian Enterprises
are opening their own shops
the foreigners have left
they have given up two million uh square
meters of trading place and millions of
rubles but almost all of that has been
compensated for taken over by Russian
business
and we have seen something like a 90 000
new registrations new business
registrations
I don't think it's any Secret
that uh
when I discuss things
with
a Russian business they actually
emphasize the fact that the Western
firms shouldn't be allowed back in
on all of these International economic
forums and meetings
the main request of me has been from
this Russian business not to allow
Western concerns back
the growth rate in this area has been 10
last year
and in fact we are covering our own
needs more or less with this uh growth
in uh in investment and interest
more and more
we are actually hearing positive
messages from Western business they can
come back if they want
and we will provide the suitable
conditions for them to work in Russia
but of course we will be thinking more
about our own future
our own domestic industry
those people who will be working for
foreign firms and so on we will consider
them to be Russian workers Russian
businessmen
for all companies like that
we have set up a an annual social
competition
and at the end of June we will be seeing
the first edition of that
and we've had something like
5 000 different
applications from different countries
and we are
seeing new investments from many
quarters
and we need to support particularly at
Regional level these new brands
there has been a real a realistic
increase here
and this is a particularly noticeable if
you compare it with the results of last
year
we're also supporting uh Regional
investment Banks to a large extent
last year
the rate of
the last rate of uh
lending has gone up
from three and nine percent to 17
percent
so I think these are very uh encouraging
figures
also we see a big increase in mortgages
a very important
Point here
is that there has been progress in
particularly in logistics transport
roads and so on and so forth
and
again we see a big increase in terms
with in terms of last year
and the volume of construction work is
also up very considerably
it is increasing and continuing
it went up by some
more than five points
five percent
infrastructure
cars roads Railways all this is covered
by this kind of area
we also see that the possibilities of
Maritime ports has also increased we
will be particularly uh looking at the
progress of markets towards the east
and to new routes
in may we
concluded a very important uh contract
with our Iranian partners
yeah
to
do building works construction works on
the Iranian Frontier
as far as the Oriental Eastern Area is
concerned
ever since 2005
we have seen a third a rise in a third
of the trade with Russia
and
we have seen the particular efficiency
of the bical so-called bical system
I would just like to note here the
success of the government interns of in
terms of increasing the volume of
containers from the East
but the main aim of course has been to
simplify administrative
procedures here
we are also concentrating on expanding
our commercial Fleet
yeah
and have
concluded a
particular program for them
and I would just say that only in terms
of the present program
the Russian Federation
has uh is has constructed more than 260
new vessels
in comparison with last year
we expect
that by 2024
the trade turnover in terms of shipping
will be much much higher
and this will be helped by
infrastructure Works particularly in
Arctic ports
I just like to also say that the work
which we are carrying forward in terms
of regional development throughout our
territory
is expanding very rapidly
and more than a thousand new uh
kilometers of roads have been built in
that area I should just like to thank
our construction workers our engineers
and so on for they're very responsible
and uh efficient work
because I think that next year we will
not only just maintain this rate of
progress but we will actually increase
it and expand it
and I'm absolutely sure that that our
plans will come true
we have also seen big progresses in
terms of communications thousands of the
kilometers of great has been installed
and in fact
in comparison with last year we have
increased that by
by a factor of three
which means that Communications now will
be established with all
points of settlement throughout the
country I just like to stress here that
the
development of the regional
markets will be very very important
particularly in terms of Tourism
domestic tourism first and foremost
that is actually grown according to the
state statistics
by
16.10 percent
we have to really develop very
qualitatively uh infrastructure links
so that the grid will be expanded even
further
and
for all these projects of course we need
a proper lending system
I think it's also very important to
point out that
we have put in place a development
program for
leisure centers
in many areas in the Russian Far East
and Caucasus areas and euros and so on
and
the development of hotels throughout
these tourist regions is also forging
ahead
uh more than four billion rubles have
been invested in this particular area
however the demand is much higher
so we have worked out an investment
structure for that uh
and I propose that in the upcoming two
years we
divot something like 11 billion rubles
to the sphere
which means that uh more people will be
able to spend their holidays uh in
nature preserves and so on
and the incentives which we are creating
will allow our business to uh expand our
commercial links with Azure with Latin
America
but all this is based on five absolute
principles fundamental principles uh
people said that we would be isolated on
the contrary we have
come up with much better relations in
terms of our trade partners
and here I'd like to repeat
that in terms of the future markets
we are interested in Partners who are
not uh going in for barbaric practices
and
We are continuing to expand our
relations with those countries
the objective Market
laws will be stronger
than the economic climate
which means that
the previous
unipolar uh system is
on the blink and what we are seeing is
the emergence of a multipolar system
we have also seen
enormous increases
5.9
in the energy sphere
and this has actually led to an increase
of 6.4 million jobs
so just like to say that the
agro-industrial complex
has involved investment of more than 40
billion uh dollars
and
we will be number one grain exporter by
2026.
and we will be seeing record dumps in
terms of exports of agricultural
products we will be exporting
particularly to African countries for
example
of uh January and April
it increased by 22.6 million dollars
and there was a huge profit made in 2022
from this kind of area so uh obviously
what we need to do is to do a lot more
in terms of the uh development of Russia
internal internal Regional areas of
Russia
and we have to stimulate
investment inward investment
particularly with regard to influ
infrastructure and logistical
projects which will allow us to expand
the economy
really right across the board
obviously Russia has not just Partners
in these areas and
and partners who are really interested
in their own profit
and who are politically
incentivated and they don't want to
allow anybody to compete with them
but to those participants
in the market they don't want
competitors so they try to
stop things put barriers in the way
and we uh determined to
get rid of them
in fact their policies are in fact
impairing their own reputations
Russia will be very much a part of the
world economy
I would just like to say in this respect
that we have
completely done away with a lot of
import duties
and that will increase in 2024 what more
our colleagues in the um
social welfare sphere
involuntary associations have asked for
uh an Amnesty on uh certain forms of
Taxation this is a very extraordinary
measure which we have hardly ever done
but we are doing
in the light of circumstances
and we should like to
completely
do away with this kind of uh practice
which we have seen from foreign partners
we have seen a lot of uh
changes in the banking sphere as well
and an acceleration in the turnover rate
of transactions
this is a separate subject in itself
that the currency which we'll be trading
in in the Eurasian
trade cooperation will be rubles from
now on
and we will be trading with other uh
countries also in Rubles so brics
countries and to these SEO countries too
in all branches of uh industry this will
be so
and we have uh extended this practice at
least until 2013.
this is going to
be a huge support to our exporters
especially in as much as they will be
opening markets with new markets so it's
very important they should be supported
and we're also making progress in terms
of uh
insurance for experts
exports
and obviously
we have to promote domestic production
in electronics
this we can see is thriving all the time
always making a Headway and that even in
the case of very small businesses
I don't want to boast but I think that
the outlook here is very very important
and we have to make sure that we push
through the support measures for the
electronics Industries as quickly as
possible
and we have to obviously encourage smes
so that they can work as efficiently as
possible
we have to help them particularly the
electronics smes to access big markets
like India China
and turkey and other countries
and this will be a two-way process as
well
and Russian purchases will
have a much better better
Spectrum from which to choose
dear friends
Russia has not
step back from its fundamental approach
to Commerce
and
we have maintained the stability of our
economy right across the board from
major industries to smes which is
no small thing
we have also
supported
labor collectives
thus they prosperity of millions of
Russian families
and today the Outlook is not just to
have compensated for the fall in
production or the fall in in economic
activity but to actually anticipate
anticipate in real time the
activities of global trade I'd just like
to repeat once again that the changes in
geopolitics has an irreversible
character
and we are we are moving only ahead
based on a practical
politics
and a responsible relationship with the
partners in the market
and we believe that this will lead to a
qualitatively uh a qualitative
difference in the uh level of trade
and the business themselves will
actually form themselves this progress
this kind of economics
economics of supply
obviously presupposes an enormous uh
development
and infrastructural Network
new modern industrial capacity will be
created
and
the scientific possibilities for that
obviously we possess ourselves at the
time
as of now
this is an economics of supply
and this has
this will have an effect on the our
immediate future
and of course we can be proud of that
however there is a reverse side of the
medal
and people on this uh in this chamber
know exactly what I'm talking about
uh we are suffering from a lack of
cardos a lack of skilled workers and
this obviously
means that employment structural
employment policies are very important
here employment is at the center of our
attention
and we have to give citizens the chance
to take part in all this and to develop
uh prospective or areas which are liable
to development
and I think that we also ought to pay
particular attention to those areas
where there is very high unemployment
uh unfortunately uh there are such areas
still which are lagging behind uh and we
have to make sure that uh the people
there get trained in new specialties
and I think that we can also think in
terms of building up uh remote working
and there are some like
10 projects uh uh on the drawing board
uh already to do that
and of course I cannot but greet
programs of that kind
and we are trying to reorientate the
work of our
educational establishments towards
results
and
kpis will now be very important in terms
of those institutions
and we are introducing a system of
rating for them
and we are also instituting a five-year
five-year scheme uh in terms of
increasing capacity and skilled workers
and the academic
academic uh agreement idea uh is also
very important
uh so that the our graduates can uh go
into a very highly skilled employment
I don't want to go into details about
that but we have actually started that
scheme
and of course we are also thinking very
much in terms of that having the
knock-on effect of the increase in wages
the minimum wage
uh is going to be continued to to be
indexed
and
we have noted an increase there in terms
of the standard of living
as from the first of uh January 2024
we will
index that further
and it will rise
from
6.3 to more than 18 which is much higher
than the rate of inflation and rate of
growth in the country as a whole
and
something like
almost 5 million people in the country
will be affected by these measures
so our aim is to double the uh minimum
wage which will have an effect on wages
policy throughout the throughout the
across the board
and of course we will be providing more
resources for families
and trying to increase the income of
such families
so
we have to make sure there is a stimulus
to find better jobs
and but there must be some kind of
supporting measures to do that
particularly for people with families
I think that unemployment really is a
great stimulus to people to go out and
look for jobs
we are increasing the child allowance to
18 months
and
we are determined to continue that
we are also I am also proposing there
should be an increase in the uh rates uh
earned by carers and people who look
after the disabled
and we have to remove limitations to the
receipt of uh allowances particularly
where unemployment is concerned uh so
that would be a change with the uh
present situation
and I have asked Parliament how they can
do that as quickly as possible
we need to
expand
smes smes now employs something like 80
million people in Russian Federation
and
we have to support people who want to go
into business
and I think we've got the first steps uh
outlined here
social contracts for example
and
this implies uh the possibility of
undergoing further training
at one of the previous meetings of our
forum
we talked about the uh lending
mechanisms for smes
particularly when uh smes do not have
enough deposits
to set up businesses
and we have actually
introduced a lot of measures
with billions of rubles to do that
and there has been a Seven Fold increase
in the employment rates of the
processing Industries and obviously we
are aiming to increase that even further
and I'm particularly concerned here with
it
Industries
and I should like the government to make
sure that there is a uh
a nominal system of lending in place for
these kind of businesses
targeted
I think it's also to expand the scope of
these measures
particularly with regard to
Industries which are going through
difficulties according to various
factors like unemployment lack of
skilled labor and so on
they need resources and they need
special support measures these
particular branches of Industry
and
of course the smes which become bigger
they lose their support
so
until such a time that they actually uh
are beneficiaries of uh of
[Music]
um
greater support they they've lost the
previous one so we have to do something
about that
so it becomes some businesses just
become non-profitable
so
they remain smes instead of going
forging ahead
and I think that there is a taxation
problem
and that has been happening Mr chairman
for some time here
and you know
people were always
find a way out
this is you know to do with the real
conditions of working in Russia
so what we have to do is to support
development
liberate forces and make sure that we
have higher skilled workers
and the measures that we are thinking
about are ones which are going to
relieve businesses
and that uh has to do with taxation
incentives
one other very important measure with
regard to businesses is uh State
controls I just like to remind you that
last year we brought in a moratorium on
inspection of Russian businesses and we
have actually extended that to 2023
but uh
businesses which are not uh particularly
endangered have also benefit from
benefited from this measure
so we have carried out 20 less
inspections than we did previously
uh that since 2019.
there's something else as well
if businesses are not a particularly
high risk
then
they do not actually need any kind of
inspection at all this is my proposal
and I think that some preventive
measures are the only thing that they
need to do
maybe you know there is something in all
this for your country as well um
don't want to boast but this may well be
useful for other countries
next year we will assess uh what I'm
proposing and obviously I
think that preventive measures are
Limited
but next year
we will
we will be further decreasing the
administrative burden on uh Industries
we are gradually transforming the whole
business climate
and in all regions of the country as
well
and business communities business
associations are really very important
here
and only they really will be in a
position to properly assess these
measures I've been talking about
and I want the government to look
at the use of artificial intelligence in
our industry as well just like to remind
you that uh
to assess business efficiency
it was the World Bank that responsible
for that
and of course there is some logic there
and we should not give up that idea but
as far as objective uh criteria a
concerned corrective evaluation
foreign
agency of which will work nationally
with the business associations and
corporations so that we will be able to
materialize all this uh on a
step-by-step basis
and of course
we have to also think we cannot not
mention the decriminalization measures
for business
yeah
we have to reduce to a minimum
any kind of criminal activity within the
business community
and
I hope very much that
nobody doubts that we will be neglecting
this particular subject
many of the measures which the
government uh is thinking about you have
in fact become laws have become shrined
in legislation
and I would also like to talk about
even more proposals
because there are a lot of laws which
are no longer uh applicable no longer
suitable so what we've been doing
uh what we've been seeing is uh quite a
a hemorage of
of property
and we have to pay particular attention
to
uh to this kind of area
so we're going to reduce the thresholds
by a factor of two
for a property
and we're going to increase
fines on criminal activity and business
speculation on Securities and so on and
so forth
and we have actually found that in the
light of the work we have been doing
this is actually been reduced very
considerably
and
we have noticed that there has been a
certain rate of success here because we
have involved the forces of Law and
Order
what we're seeing is a
replacement of attitudes
and this kind of semi-criminal activity
is actually subverted industry
so
we must make sure that where there are
those uh particular defects we address
them
we have to strictly
follow through the
um the sense of the legislative past
legislation look at it very carefully
and we have to make sure that we exert a
much uh closer
more careful control of such areas
mature businesses must also be globally
competitive
and
our biggest industries must must work
under Russian law
and any kind of business
has to be subjected to this system
the situation where
profits from business come from uh
foreign trade this is simply not
acceptable
and we have to make sure that the
situation is turned round
some people have
in the West
there has been a total
plundering or
violation of all the uh rules of the
Russian jurisdictional area
but
I've said this a lot about our business
we have to make sure that investment is
made in Russia
and I think that there will be big
profits to be gained here
investments in the social welfare area
and in our citizens
will uh bring really big profit
reliable profit
and Russian citizens uh
for them to
special areas including kalinograd have
been outlined more earmarked rather as
special
for taxation preferential taxation
these people have previously not been
able to make it often because of the
insistence of unfriendly foreign Nations
who simply don't want to allow a Russian
businessman on their markets so I think
that we obviously have to accelerate
measures here
and to simplify the procedure
for registering Uh Russian business
especially when they are being blocked
by foreign countries
we have to uh follow that through to
December of next year and to launch a
system of measures or for legislative
legal protection
for uh companies in difficulty in this
area
it's a quite obvious from
looking at what's happening that some
people really fell foul of this whole
system of trying to
um
trying to
export their profits
so for owners of Industries
it is very important that we support
them from a uh legal
point of view
all these proposals friends
are aimed at uh increasing competencies
and increasing domestic production
and some something like three trillion
rubles will be sacrificed by this state
to that end next year
and a whole
raft of measures will be
introduced as I said to support business
at the end of February
the so-called cluster cluster platform
was introduced and that will give the
possibility of taking out loans at lower
interest rates than the banks
and this will be very important for
businesses
and preference will be given to those
Industries which can uh
uh increase the assembly line in the
next three years
and in the energy
sector particularly
we have to make sure that we take our
decisions with regard to vital economic
interests
we need technological
commercial agreements with a friendly
partner States
and
this we need we have to make sure that
we increase the financial basis of such
businesses
there are 26 very major uh projects in
question here
okay
fertilizers coal and ports
Logistics around the Baikal for example
and another
another
um
seven projects are worth some 345
billion rubles have also been approved
so the
technological sovereignty of Russia has
to be protected and supported
um
we have other supportive measures also
to the tune of 200 billion rubles
uh
and
obviously we have to tap the
uh chapter the potential of the Russian
fund
for our best Industries
obviously uh they obtaining Securities
here can be based on different criteria
but the Russian banks at the moment are
actually doing that
and we are launching a special in
Project here uh or measure rather
to encourage people
uh
there are private Equity Funds
which are very important play a very
important role here
this can be unblocked
freed up
as I said in my address we are
supporting the release of Equity Funds
for the development of I.T Industries
particularly
and we have to encourage uh purchases of
these Securities and a special decision
has been taken in that regard
and
the shares of
companies
has to be done through the Russian Stock
Exchange
a very
we have to
rely here on the long-term interests of
the Russian purchases
where the state guarantees the return of
funds so let me just repeat that we have
to have a situation whereby people are
investing in Russia and actually plowing
back the results into Russia
in Moscow and here in Saint Petersburg
uh
we have a whole
raft of measures to encourage investment
and we have to help particularly the
other regions of the country which
simply haven't got enough resources to
take advantage of uh all these new
developments
so first and foremost we have to
accentuate the importance of the regions
then in addition we have to make sure
that there are equal criteria in place
for uh launching new projects for all
regions
and we have to look at the taxation
measures in all of those cases
unfortunately we can't say that the new
mechanism is
fully is perfect
so we have to
uh increase the efficiency of the
taxation system there
and as I said one of the most important
things for the future is to ensure the
I.T sovereignty of the country
as I said from next year on the regions
will be able to benefit from this a
whole new taxation regime obviously
there are risks here in lending to
Regions and so on but uh I think that
that is you know something we can work
on
let me just repeat
that the important thing here is to
encourage business
we have a team of government which is
dedicated to that purpose
and we have to make sure that our
ratings in terms of the whole country
goes up
so the Chechen Republic is comes top in
terms of regions Saratov
ninetsky and Baikal regions are also
very uh you know up in the top ratings
there so I wish you success
services are also in a central part of
this new
um
Supply economy
and all that
is covered by the term uh cautious
production
this we can see how these new measures
are actually being very
increasing efficiency
we have to make sure that successes
ensured not only in the basic Industries
the uh major industries but in smes and
uh in the welfare area
artificial intelligence of course cannot
be neglected here
so it is absolutely essential to make
sure that we increase automatization
and
that will affect transport and
infrastructure in particular Russia has
not only a huge potential here but
um decision making capacity as well and
I think that this forum is well aware of
that
for example there is a driverless
Yandex taxi which has been launched in
Moscow this is a very good thing but
it's only the beginning
industrial robots are very important to
I'm told that they are going to be
introduced to a much greater scale as
from the first of July this will be
critical for our economy
and then we need to have a management
system which is based on results this
should be across the board in creating
increasing including in education we
have to
support the national programs here
in the creation of artificial
intelligence for example
specific activity has actually on this
score has been agreed but we have to
accelerate it
and in the near future
well very soon we will be hearing a
presentation with
about that
we have an annual conferences so uh
devoted to artificial intelligence and
uh
we have a particular form called Forum
of future Technologies
which will begin this year
companies educational establishments and
so on will be presenting their results
and the first Forum will happen uh very
soon in July
and uh obviously we have to pay great
attention to data processing
we have to make sure that whole markets
are encompassed by these uh new
artificial means robot robotization and
artificial intelligence
let me repeat we have to access more and
more areas and institutes
to form our economic future our
technological based future
and that will of course
be incorporated in on an EV everyday
basis in Russian industry
and in terms of uh
digitalization we are one of the leading
countries in the world
dear friends uh
the context of this forum does not allow
us to deal in all aspects of what is
happening in the economy of Russia but
I'd just like to point out that a
detailed
uh detailed processing of all these
measures is the task of the Russian
government
and uh
we have to make sure that
our economic growth
is in line with the increase in prices
due to inflation
the inflation at the end of the year I
think will be in the region of five
percent uh this is not only for Russian
Banks but also for production units
throughout the country so I should like
to to pay particular attention to that
and I just like also to emphasize the
need that there should be a real uh
economic
payback for uh
government schemes
this will be very important when we draw
up the next three-year budget
in this connection I'd just like to
mention also
the whole idea of this Supply economy
where there is Supply there must be
demand
and it has to be connected with an
increase in the welfare of our citizens
I'd like to end here what with what I
began
the need to look at unemployment and to
keep inflation down we have to make sure
that the real income of Russian citizens
Rises
professional importance of professional
education vocational education is very
very important as I said before
to make sure that we can fill the highly
skilled jobs which are being required at
the moment
all this obviously will have a knock-on
effect on increasing the uh
International standing rating of the
country
it is impossible to actually increase
the level of uh
the level of artificial intelligence
production and so on if we have low
School workers so
once we have this in place demand will
increase and
we will be aiming at a sovereign
industry
we have been in conclusion
really up against the wall a huge number
of logistical and financial problems
I just like to repeat though uh what I
said recently at a different forum
and that is that cooperation at all
levels of government
is absolutely essential for businesses
and
we have to ensure the industrial and
agricultural sovereignty of the country
and we have to support government
investments in infrastructure structures
and ecological structures
and all this has to be in line with the
growth of wages
and Welfare and I should like you
pleased to pay particular attention to
that
Russia has an incredibly ambitious
economic uh
agenda here this is a stimulus
for all of us
to increase the rate of development
and to aim at uh more for every citizen
and I think this will strengthen our
sovereignty in all areas
and it will open up the possibility of
uh Fair equal uh competition between all
countries and where each country
including Russia will determine its own
future thank you
thank you for your patience
I thank you
pleasure villagers thank you very much
for that very impressive speech
before giving the floor though to the
president of Algeria
I would like to ask a couple of
questions you talk a lot
about very important subjects and also
uh uh cited very big statistics and
figures with regard to the way forward
for Russia it's uh prosperity and
Welfare the development of the Russian
economy all this of course is very
positive and so on
and
I'd just like to emphasize that all this
is happening of course against the
backdrop of the Ukrainian war and a very
very complicated International context
and
what
we would very much like to hear from you
what uh is actually happening militarily
in
London
and Washington and many other countries
in the west uh they're talking a lot
about the Ukrainian counter-offensive
and what is actually happening has not
actually Justified the the expectations
of the collective West
and it turns out that
this is not
tactical successes on the part of the
ukrainians but
what interests me in particular
is that this has happened actually
without touching uh the Russian front
line
but
it would appear that Ukrainian equipment
is being worn out before it actually
gets into
full contact with the front line Russian
front line
the ukrainians are being trained in the
west and so on what do you think about
this situation
and how serious do you think it is
although quite clearly from your
presentation you are optimistic about
how Russia is actually dealing with that
situation
well I have just have a meeting with our
War correspondence and I'd just like to
remind you that
the war
in Ukraine was begun by the Ukrainian
regime with the support of their Western
uh sponsors in 2014 and everybody
tries to avoid speaking about that in
the west so I have to remind everybody
that
Aviation bombing and artillery and so on
began then in the donbass
and that is war
and then
uh
Western Partners actually categorically
refused to
to
support the agreements under Russia
asked and they asked us to stop these
aggressions
but we know how will this began
when they signed their Minsk agreements
they
publicly said that they were not
interested in stopping it
they said it in public
so I was just forced to use the Armed
Forces
in response to the request of the
Donetsk and uh in order to stop this
armed uh operation that's the first
thing secondly
we can see that Western countries are
taking the utmost efforts
to make sure that there is a tactical uh
defeat of Russia on the field
but we
have made sure that our aim is
denotification and demilitarization of
Ukraine
but as far as the demonstrationization
is concerned
soon Ukraine will
stop actually using its own equipment
everybody knows uh what they're using
and it's all brought in from outside
whereas
our defense industry
is increasing its productivity day by
day
something like 2.77 percent
uh recently
and it is growing by a factor of 10.
and this tells us that
we have a lot of capacity in hand
as far as the counter-offensive is
concerned then
sometimes you know they succeed
sometimes we succeed so but essentially
what we need to remember is that they're
using their strategic Reserves
response
and
but they haven't actually succeeded in
making sure that their troops enter uh
territories obviously losses are very
big
but I think it's something like 10 times
more than the Russian army that's a fact
in terms of uh equipment
they are increasing
day by day
I think that uh 180 tanks were lost by
the Ukrainian Army
and uh 168 armored cars uh
I'm not talking about actual casualties
that's been uh
announced by the ministry of Defense
there has been no success here
as we speak there's been an attempt
by the adversary to attack
there is a
tank units
and
two tanks and the armored cards were
involved
they lost a couple of Tanks
and you know combat was engaged or is
engaged right as we speak
but I think that the Ukrainian Armed
Forces has no chances at all
I have no doubt about that at all thank
you very much
you have annoyed with the collective
West particularly by your announcement
that the Kiev regime is a Nazi one
and they say zelinski is a legitimate uh
president
and in fact he is uh fighting against
everything bad in Russia so how would
you reply to that
well I've got a lot of Jewish friends uh
and they say that he can't be a Jew it's
shameful to call him a Jew
and that's not uh a joke or irony
the heroes of Ukraine are now
considered
the neo-nazis and the uh accomplices of
uh Hitler
six million Jews died in the uh
Holocaust and half of them were in
Ukraine and particularly at the hands of
the Banderas
I didn't doubt that you would ask me
this question so
I prepared the following notes
Steve
one of the leaders was
from
in 39
Moscow and the jury are the biggest
enemies of Ukraine he said
so we have to employ the same kind of
methods of the Nazis with the Jews
Andy
German unit in some stepan likovski's
rights as far as the Jews are concerned
we will apply all the
all methods to lead to the complete
Annihilation what does that actually
mean
it's the
testimony of some monster
after the war he said
that he had shot a whole uh uh Jewish
Family you you just can't read it
without a lump in your throat
and I think you know the whole family
the wife the the the daughter
uh 18 18 years old daughter
and they all knew
that they were going to be shot
and they
shot children children
one and a half million Jews were killed
like that
I'm not talking about Russians or polls
who haven't actually forgotten what
happened in those years in Ukraine
but we're talking about the Holocaust at
the moment
you know what
I apologize but uh
to the chairman
I knew that you would ask me this
we're always talking and talking about
the same thing
Bandera was an
anti-semite and Neo-Nazi but nobody
actually wants to hear that
and he zelinski is actually covering up
for these uh monsters
why does he put these Nazis on pedestals
so he can do what he likes as the leader
of the government but this is something
outrageous
it's an excerpt from what happened in
1941 babiar
that's
a short video